local organization working on several
homes in the valley that some would call
isource 8 News now's Joshua peguero
follows volunteers helping homeowner
homeowners remodel their homes
they were shoveling gravel
and painting
volunteers at least 20 of them gave
their time to repair this Henderson home
we see homeowners that haven't had air
conditioning for three years or they
haven't had hot water for two years
their roof's been leaking for a couple
years and it just the maintenance just
becomes too much for them Rebuilding
Together of Southern Nevada helps
homeowners who are disabled veterans or
seniors the non-profit already replaced
the roof doors and Floors on this house
they even installed an AC unit
volunteers are working on 19 homes on
Saturday similar to the one that you see
right here they're all over Clark County
but their specific Target are those who
are low income they're barely getting by
on what they have for food and medicine
and then you have a repair that's going
to cost twelve thirteen thousand dollars
they have nowhere else to go
Cheryl Canales was walking her dog when
she saw all the commotion there are
still people out there that will come
and give up their time and do good for
other people and I think that's great
that's we should all do that Canales
lives two houses down and says this home
needed work I was even contemplating
pulling weeds there but I think it's a
good thing that they're doing brings the
property values up here for all of us
and you know support support our
neighbors as for the dozens of
volunteers working up a sweat on this
weekend they do it again it feels great
it's just putting a smile into their
face you know sometimes it's it's hard
shape and what we try to do is try to
put a smile and try to help out the
community Joshua piguero eight news now
now the organization says it will do
work on about a thousand homes this year
more of the homeowners make around 23
thousand dollars a year